[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Santa Shawn coming at you from a warm
cozy Museum of curiosities and what a
year it's been you know from Gordon
Ramsay in January all the way through
our season 10 finale I can't tell you
how much it warms our spicy hearts here
at the show to see the way you guys have
rocked with us and this is now my fourth
year coming at you from the cozy fire
and it's that time to answer your
hard-hitting season 10 year in Review
hot ones fan questions
Sean burger he's already booked his
flight he's taken off he's probably on a
beach somewhere but don't worry
Dom has got the bucket of questions
we've reached out to you at Twitter we
reached out to you on YouTube we reached
out to you wherever the hell we can
reach out to you and here's what you've
come back with come on in Dom don't be
shy I know you love the spotlight let's
dig in this first question coming in
strong from fresh urinal cakes if you
had to pick a person from the last
century who is no longer with us to be a
guest on hot ones who would it be and
why I think the greatest possible guest
of all time from the last century if we
could bring them back would be Chris
Farley Chris Farley would be the goat
hot ones guest put it in stone Chris
Farley that's for you fresh urinal cakes
all right back into the bucket we got a
lot we got a lot from Oh bro show what
is your favorite meme made from an
episode I've had many favorites over the
years post Malone with his sunglasses
upside down the ones that the internet
mined out of the Paul Rudd episode are
probably the best uses of them it was
crazy when the Washington Nationals won
the World Series they put up the look at
us meme so that look at us look at us
who would have thought not me that was
everywhere and cracked us up every
single time but goat hot ones meme
forever and always
Idris Elba roll
tape gets me every time
okay let's go back into the bucket this
is from Joop van houten tell us about
your hobbies outside of your career man
what are you doing your spare time you
play games ever snowboarded much love
I'm a simple man I basically work
constantly watch a lot of football go to
the gym whenever I can and then the
other thing that I love to do is travel
I wish I could do it a little bit more
but this year I was excited to go to San
Tropez South of France was lovely I went
to London I love that took a road trip
to San Francisco love Malibu
whenever I get that a little 3-day
weekend between seasons Malibu beach in
chefs kiss
but I've also loved going to the movies
whenever I'm in LA I'm an arc light
Rewards member so here they are my top
five favorite films of the year once
upon a time in Hollywood parasite Joker
mid summer and peanut butter Falcon why
do I look so sad right now
Shia LaBeouf voice alright let's go back
into the bucket this next one is from
Keo Wilson when will you do a
presidential debate hot one style this
is something we talk about constantly
the logistics are little mind boggling
so no promises but it's something we're
working towards maybe we can bring the
wings of death to the 2020 race we would
only do it if we could use the platform
in a positive way to get more
information to people in an entertaining
way so you know they can make their own
decisions and we're not just pushing an
agenda making cause you know more noise
around this conversation which in this
day and age is already so noisy but we
are excited about the possibility
there's some nibbles some interest some
flirting so it's about us coming up with
that big idea and seeing how we can make
that happen so the wheels are turning
again the logistics cray
but it is something that we're hopeful
we're hopeful rofl so maybe we'll see
the wings of death in the 2020 race only
time will tell
alright back into the bucket from t we
get a lot of hip-hop artists but not
many metal artists can we see some heavy
metal musicians take on the wings we're
always excited to explore new genres
hip-hop we've worked with a lot of
artists in the past it's something we
have access to those are some of our
favorite interviews and then it's the
foundation on which this show was built
in a lot of ways so we love hip-hop
we love having hip-hop artists love when
rappers are in the hot seat but we're
always excited to explore other genres
as well and you guys do a great job of
letting us know who you want it was
great to get Knoll Gallagher in the seat
in season 10 that was one of my favorite
episodes of the season so keep the
suggestions coming we're always
exploring always looking for ways in
which we can dip our toes into other
genres all right up next
Christian kiss to do who has surprised
you the most as far as media perception
to actually meeting the celebrity some
of the episodes that I'm personally most
proud of are the ones where there are
all these preconceived notions about a
guest and then hot ones shows a
different side of that person you know I
love when we make the announcement and
everybody when I went and then the
episode shows a totally different side
of that person I thought Kristen had a
really eye-opening point you know think
about if you're talking to someone just
in real life and they're not all that
interested in what they're asking you
let alone what you have to say about it
just think about how you would react to
that in real life now add to that
cameras and love mics and the fact that
this conversation is just gonna be
broadcast to the public where they can
give it a thumbs up or a thumbs down I
try to attack it from a point of not
having any sort of judgment and giving
the person free rein to take and fill
this room like a gas rather than trying
to put them in a box or put them and
freeze them in an ice cube and then
present that to the world so it's a
little more each hot ones episode is
sort of an extension of the guests
personality and we work hard to give
them that space in that spotlight
so that is that's my foolish that's my
official philosophy when it comes to
that sort of thing great question and
I'm having you acid all right up next
what's the craziest thing a guest
brought with them to the show thinking
back on the history of hot ones there
have been a lot of crazy ones from Nouri
bringing Tiger bone to Gordon Ramsay's
big bag of tricks we've had guests bring
ice cream you name it we've had guests
bring it but my favorite will still
always and forever be when Hannibal
Buress
showed up to his interview way too early
and then just sort of walked around
outside the building got cryotherapy and
went to Ross's and brought activated
charcoal to the hot one see that's
that'll always be my favorite all right
up next Zeno fire X you always have the
best intros for your guests if camera
guy build a right one for you what would
it sound like there's only one way to
find out
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody
for first we FaceTime camera guy bill
and you're watching hot ones it's the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings today I'm but this is hard all the
time hey what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm camera guy bill and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
today I'm joined by Chicago's own Sean
Evans he's a Webby Award winner a game
show host and the host with the master
questions on the wildly popular YouTube
show hot ones Sean welcome to the show
did I do it how was that yeah love you
buddy love you too alright back behind
the camera back behind the camera bill
and we're back alright next question
from roschmann yet another season came
to an end and none of the fans guess
wish list was fulfilled not just Keanu
Reeves but I saw none of the celebrities
from the comment coming to the show
first of all shut up I mean look at the
last look at the last three seasons look
at the last three seasons and look I'm
um I'm the biggest critic of hot ones
trust me trust me the last three seasons
have [ __ ] begged begged and I really
just need to kind of ride for my team
right now because we worked so hard and
we have had a lot of balls bounce our
way in 2019 to make this whole thing
come together so if you have a problem
with the guest list after the year that
we have just had with Paul Rudd and Shia
LaBeouf and Gordon Ramsay and Stone Cold
Steve Austin and Idris Elba and like a
bajillion others that I can't think of
because it's just banged so hard I'm
just gonna say now I'm just gonna say
now stop watching the show because it
will not get better than this if you're
a hot ones fan I will say this and again
biggest critic but if you're a hot ones
fan twenty nine
Dean was a very good year you sound like
an entitled little crybaby and I will
not stand for it got a ride for my team
on this one because it's the best year
that we've had by a [ __ ] mile so if
you're a hot ones fan 20:19 was a good
year not going to apologize for that
statement rash mitt I was about to say I
was about to say s a d or e to a why do
you never respond to emails that's from
nacho hunters chris Shawn burger let's
listen listen I have got over a hundred
thousand unread emails if you're trying
to email me you're not gonna get to me
texting me it's still a coin flip you
know a lot of messages a lot of things
coming in and what I've found is if it's
that important it'll get to me one way
or another so I it's good to shut off
and since the show never shuts off since
I stuff shuts off I just shut off my
phone my email whatever so if you
emailed me or you texted me you're like
oh like what Shawn doesn't respond to me
anymore no no no no it's not that it's
just like I'm overwhelmed by it it's
it's a big it's a bit looks like there's
been a blizzard outside and it's now
just getting higher and higher and
higher and I'm like [ __ ] it I'm never
I'm never shovel in that driveway last
question how do you decompress after an
interview the deep dives into people's
lives the hot sauce and the intensity of
such connection and engagement with one
little tradition that I value a lot like
sometimes at the end of season finale me
and hot ones creator Chris Schoenberger
will go for old fashions and will always
go for one but it'll turn into four and
then we'll just stumble out of the
Harvard club like [ __ ] puking on our
shoes so that's a tradition that I'll
always love and look back on fondly but
other than that you know the show keeps
going on it just goes on well there you
have it the bucket is empty which means
we say farewell to another year of hot
ones 2019 I've said it a couple times
this QA it just felt great and it's all
thanks to you guys we've now rocked with
us from season one and a yellow
tablecloth all the way through season
ten and hopefully beyond I can't tell
you how much it means to us you
show you've really fueled and motivated
and given this thing what it needs to
last this long and to grow as big as it
has so all of the holiday wishes all of
the love it all goes to you yes you you
watching us on your technological
connecting there are a lot of exciting
things happening between now and our
season 11 premieres so keep it locked -
first we feast and of course that
premiere without ones you know it's
always just around the corner Happy
Holidays to you and yours from us here
at first we feast we love you baby I'm
about to start crying I feel like I'm on
touched by an angel right now Luke oh
there goes you're amazing at this man
you did a great job today
you can do anything you put your mind to
yeah you're welcome by the way
I'm a credit to the [ __ ] world all
the way down the chicken wing gauntlet
[Applause]
the red flag that's that's they waved
the red flag when someone's a champion
we have big old lobster hand [ __ ] oh no
sorry Sean that's a very nice shirt
Cheers two hot ones hey what's going on
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in to say thank you so much for
watching today's video and have a very
exciting announcement for our hot ones
hot sauce box subscribers we have gone
completely bizarro world in the December
box take a look at what I mean we have
taken pepper X from the last dab and we
have put it in the classic the classic
but with a kick we have taken the chile
de árbol from the classic put it in the
last dab mild it out a little bit and
then we've taken red jalapeno and put it
in los caliente slows calientes look at
it it's red I don't know if we'll ever
do this again but it will be in the
December box for our hot ones hot sauce
box subscribers if you're not a
subscriber and you want to get your
hands on the bizarro pack heat Ness com
heat Ness calm to subscribe thank you
very much and Happy Holidays to you and
yours from us here at hot ones
[Music]
bang-bang
[Music]